each of us pick for golfers you couldn't
pick one of the top 10 favorites and
then you got the prize money totaled up
and the loser the guy who had the least
amount of money for his for golfers that
the PGA Championship gets two dozen eggs
not poured on his head today so Paulie
will do that shower of shame
I of course pick Justin Thomas as I
normally do when it comes to the majors
whether it's a favorite or not and then
he comes through in flying colors so
thank you Justin you prevented me from
getting two dozen eggs poured on my head
thank you you know I've never been able
to say you're welcome for not giving
this [ __ ] your head but you're
welcome did you know that I picked you
going into the final round and did that
have any impact on your play
you know I the word was spreading around
the ring and I knew that I needed to
Kyra take it to another level to prevent
any sort of humiliation for you so I was
I was thinking about you going down the
stretch there are you at home today I am
okay now this is what I'm thinking
because Fowler lives just down the block
right okay
you have Ricky come over and then you
have the championship trophy there maybe
maybe not on the front step but like the
kitchen table where you have to look
around the championship trophy to talk
to him tell him just a bit like can you
rub it in a little bit since he is a
good buddy yeah that trophy's pretty
much been either in my lap in my arms
and next to me since ever since I took
it home with me yesterday and we freakin
I salute him together so he was um he's
a good sport about it I mean I've been
in the position before where you're with
your really really happy for your
friends but you're also jealous and and
you get to celebrate it a little bit
with them but um easy then it gets
forward about it so I will I won't be
too aggressive sort of can you put beer
in the trophy
you sure can the work it is you can fit
42 in there I'm probably going to wait a
little bit to see how many of it in
there because I have a couple days to
unwind and I just a distraction so far
I'll get back to you come maybe October
November if we had a beer event
with the pros where you had to drink
while you're playing who's the number
one seed I mean I think you have to go
with John Daly oh oh yeah yeah yeah
that's yeah yeah
he's the Jack Nicklaus of that event
yeah I mean I think he'd be you'd be the
captain of the a team I say four
chickens perfect yeah if we did like a
President's Cup a Ryder Cup
I want daily daily would be my number
one pick there if it found out about it
after my let's do all right a couple of
things when did you know that but I
believe it or not I thought the biggest
shot you had is on the first green where
you kept away from a double bogey and
you just had a bogan you just sort of
survived the first hole I know everybody
looks at the back nine and the whole
Green Mile and everything I look back on
that went your whole round could have
come crashing down on you at that first
that first green what did you think of
that part at the time it was huge it
that's like you said I mean that was you
never know what happens if I'm this
ephod I mean I'd like to think that I
could um so I was mentally strong enough
to where I could have overcame at but
then again it's a big big stage and yeah
it happened at the US Open but I still
wasn't as familiar with it it's maybe
some others and I mean I was just trying
to you know I was trying to just kind of
minimize the damage like you have to do
out there I mean bogeys are you know
hard to make up the doubles are really
really hard to make up but of course
they're difficult so it was just about
you know trying to minimize the damage
and try not to give up to there when
really I was in a great position to make
par so that was uh although it was a
pretty bad bogey after two shots or
after the drive but it was a great bogey
looking back at it how long are you
allowed to wait before you go up to you
know the putt word is hanging on the lip
what is it 10 seconds that you're
allowed to have what is the universal
rule on that or is there one yes oh
you're allowed ten seconds to once
you're there so I mean you can you
basically can but I kind of like I did
now I was and shocking and all whatever
but away from the place and the ball
that's fine but then once you go up to
the ball and you're basically addressing
it or about to finish it or waiting at
the ball then you're allowed 10 seconds
and I was fortunate that I didn't even
get to that point I was glad that felon
before him could you ask the gallery to
make noise could you have signaled to
them like make noise are you allowed to
do that
at that that's a good question
hopefully I'll just try to make putts in
the middle and I don't have to say about
that yeah but I wonder because it looked
like
hideki Matsuyama already wrote down what
your score was yeah it was bizarre it
really was but it was something to wear
when it once it kind of crept up on the
hole and once it sat on the lift there I
as weird as it was I had a c1 that was
going to drop at some point I really did
because it's just you can tell when a
balls sitting on the lip and it's not
going to go in and you can tell when it
has a good chance and this one looked
like it had a good chance because of the
the slope of the green going that way in
the grain was going that way so
everything was kind of trending that way
or hoping that it was hoping that it
would fall and I was just happy that it
he's a Justin Thomas PGA champion is
getting Patrick show you ever play golf
with Nick Saban
I haven't actually played of rounded off
with them but I've spent a lot of times
on the golf course listen I'm outside I
guess I played a couple holes with them
and I've been around the range around a
bunch but never a full 18 holes is
playing is playing going from the SEC
similar to playing football in the SEC
as far as the spirit competition level I
know what their our body saw they don't
hurt quite a guy the next morning it
just got beautiful I mean there's some
some big boys and the SEC and football
and I mean I remember my my recruiting
visit serve are now going back to games
and going down on the field before the
games and just watching those guys warm
up and I mean the fact that they're 18
19 years old and I mean they could
legitimately just pick me up and throw
me or just looks like they could eat me
if they want to do is absurd and
so deep and and as you see were strong
in golf when I was well when I was at
college and I'm sure it's are going to
continue down that road they probably
look at you as a kicker maybe if you
showed up well like a water play outs
did you know that that was jordan Spieth
hitting you in the slapping you on the
butt after you won I didn't I honestly
didn't everything was pretty much a blur
after that last pot went in and at about
three hours of media the course
afterwards and just kind of hanging
around and doing different stops here
and there and it was just all blurry I
was bit fazham be when I walked out of
there I didn't know who I was what had
happened and I just know that I was
tired and that and I wanted to get home
and sleep in my own bed and it was uh I
didn't I saw I didn't know that he did
it I turned around and once he said
something and I saw and then I saw the
video I think from somebody it was
pretty funny how many times in the last
ten years his jordan Spieth hit you in
the groin you know even if I did know
the answer to that question I don't know
I'm stirring it well the fact that he
wins the Open Championship and then
gives his caddy a cup check after he
wins yeah on camera happen yeah that was
pretty funny we we bust his chops pretty
good for that one and his caddy but do
you pull pranks on him or she pulled
pranks on you who's better at it
um I mean with the thing about Jordan is
I pranked him I mean we will mess around
and pull jokes on each other but I prank
them a little bit more than usual like
that my rookie year and then he got me
back really good by moving my car from
the courtesy car lot into a different
lot because I parked his parking spot
and mmm and it was me and he moved my
car so that's the thing about Jordans
he's going to go over the top and
overreact so I kind of can't go there
with him because he's one of those he's
like that six year old that you know
your little brother when you when you
kind of push him he retaliates a lot
worse so I I kind of don't want to go
there anymore and we're just we just
kind of poked fun of each other can you
could you take him again
- oh absolutely not he's a lot bigger
than I but you hinted a lot farther than
he does yeah yeah I guess I don't know
why or how I mean he's gotten a lot
longer these last three or four years
and he's put a lot of muscle on a lot of
weight on and happens I've been working
hard in the gym this year too just to
try to get stronger and not in certain
places and yeah it is weird how I hit it
farther than a lot of people who are
bigger than I am but but he's definitely
getting up there Congrats
a lot of fun there yesterday and the
fact your dad was there to see it as
well and good luck the rest of the
season Justin thanks for joining us
absolutely thanks Jeremy out net that's
a Justin Thomas PGA golfer I believed in
him nobody else did as I picked him to
win the PGA Championship the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience